ARE ANY OTHER BIG HEADLINES
TONIGHT, WOLF.
>> LET OUR VIEWERS KNOW.
THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT REPORTING AS USUAL.
>>> NOW TO THE FIRST PUBLIC LOOK
AT DONALD TRUMP'S TAX RETURNS.
MADE PUBLIC BY THE HOUSE
DEMOCRATS EARLIER TODAY AFTER
THE FORMER PRESIDENT KEPT THEM
SECRET FOR YEARS.
CNN NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT
KRISTIN HOLMES TAKES US THROUGH
THESE DOCUMENTS AND WHAT THEY
REVEALED.
>> Reporter: LITTLE OR NO INCOME
TAX, FOREIGN BANK ACCOUNTS AND
EYE-BROWSE RAYING DETAILS ABOUT
LOANS TO HIS ADULT CHILDREN.
JUST SOME OF THE FINDINGS AFTER
THE HOUSE WAYS AN MEANS
COMMITTEE RELEASED SIX YEARS
WORTH OF FORMER TRUMP'S TAX
RETURNS.
THE RETURNS SPANNING FROM THE
YEAR TRUMP ANNOUNCED HIS FIRST
RUN FOR PRESIDENT IN 2015
THROUGH HIS LAST YEAR IN OFFICE,
2020.
>> THE RESEARCH THAT WAS DONE AS
IT RELATES TO THE MANDATORY
AUDIT PROGRAM WAS NONEXISTENT.
THE TAX FORMS WERE REALLY NEVER
AUDITED.
>> Reporter: PREVIOUS REPORTS
FROM THE JOINT COMMITTEE ON
TAXATION REVEALED LOW TAX
AMOUNTS PAID BY THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
INCLUDING PAYING ONLY $750 IN
2017.
AND IN 2018 AND '19, PAYING A
COMBINED $1.1 MILLION.
AND PAYING NO INCOME TAX IN
2020, HIS FINAL YEAR IN OFFICE.
TRUMP OFFSETTING HIS INCOME BY
CLAIMING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
LOSSES RAISING QUESTIONS ABOUT
HIS BUSINESS FAILURES.
AND WHILE TRUMP PAID LESS THAN
$1,000 IN U.S. INCOME TAX IN
2017, THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S TAX
BILL TOTALED NEARLY A MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE SAME YEAR,
INDICATING BUSINESS DEALINGS IN
MORE THAN A DOZEN COUNTRIES
INCLUDING AZERBAIJAN AND TURKEY
AND CHINA AND ISRAEL AND BRAZIL.
SHEDDING LIGHT ON WHERE TRUMP'S
BUSINESS INTERESTS WERE WHILE HE
WAS IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE RETURNS ALSO SHOWED TRUMP
MAINTAINED FOREIGN BANK ACCOUNTS
WHILE SERVING IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
INCLUDING IN CHINA.
SOME OF TRUMP'S BUSINESS
SPENDING RAISING EYEBROWS AMONG
EXPERTS INCLUDING A 2017 CLAIM
THAT ONE OF HIS BUSINESSES, DJT
AEROSPACE, MADE EXACTLY THE SAME
AMOUNT SPENT.
THE ZERO NET INSURING THERE WAS
NOTHING TO TAX.
SOMETHING ONE TAX EXPERT
REFERRED TO AS A, QUOTE,
STATISTICAL IMPOSSIBILITY.
>> MY PERSONAL TAX RETURNS,
WOULD SHOW ONLY THAT I'VE HAD
TRAEMZ SUCCESS.
>> Reporter: TRUMP BLASTING THE
RELEASE AS A ABUSE OF POWER AND
CALLING FOR REPUBLICANS TAKING
CONTROL OF THE HOUSE TO
IMMEDIATELY INVESTIGATE BIDEN
AND HIS FAMILY'S FINANCES.
>> IT IS SO SAD FOR OUR COUNTRY.
IT IS NOTHING BUT ANOTHER
DERANGED POLITICAL WITCH HUNT
WHICH HAS BEEN GOING ON FROM THE
DAY I CAME DOWN THE ESCALATOR IN
TRUMP TOWER.
>> Reporter: AND ANOTHER THING
TO NOTE HERE IS THAT THIS
APPEARS TO BE A MAJOR FAILURE ON
THE PART OF THE IRS.
REMEMBER, THERE IS A MANDATORY
PROGRAM THAT IS SUPPOSED TO
AUDIT PRESIDENTS OF THE UNITED
STATES AND THAT WAS NOT DONE
DURING TRUMP'S TENURE.
SO SOME OF THIS COULD HAVE BEEN
CAUGHT, WOLF.
>> YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
KRISTEN HOLMES, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
>>> LET'S DISCUSS WHAT IS GOING
ON WITH CNN LEGAL ANALYST GARY
CORDERO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
YOU LOOK AT TRUMP'S MAJOR
BUSINESS LOSSES, POTENTIAL
DISCREPANCIES HERE FOR AUDITORS,
FOREIGN BANK ACCOUNTS INCLUDING
IN CHINA DURING HIS PRESIDENCY.
WHAT STANDS OUT TO YOU FROM THE
NEW DETAILS?
>> WELL I THINK ONE OF THE
ISSUES IS THAT THE IRS HAS HAD
THIS INFORMATION FOR VERY LONG
TIME.
IT IS JUST BECOMING PUBLIC NOW.
SO I DO TEND TO THINK IF THERE
WAS GOING TO BE ANY KIND OF
FEDERAL ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM,
THAT THAT PROBABLY WOULD ALREADY
BE UNDERWAY.
BUT IT DOES PROVIDE A WHOLE NEW
LEVEL OF TRANSPARENCY.
THE FOREIGN ASPECT OF IT, I
THINK IT UNDERSCORES THE
CONCERNS THAT MANY IN THE
NATIONAL SECURITY COMMUNITY HAD
WHEN HE WAS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT AND WHEN HE WAS
PRESIDENT.
THAT HIS FOREIGN BUSINESS
DEALINGS COULD HAVE IMPACTED HIS
DECISIONS AS PRESIDENT.
AND SO THE FACT THAT HE HAD
BUSINESS INTERESTS THERE, THAT
HE PAID TAXES TO FOREIGN
COUNTRIES THAT HE HAD TAX BILLS
TO -- TO A VARIETY OF FOREIGN
COUNTRIES WITH INTERSECTING
NATIONAL SECURITY INTERESTS WITH
THE UNITED STATES RAISES
QUESTIONS FROM A GOVERNANCE
PERSPECTIVE IF NOT A LEGAL
PERSPECTIVE.
>> HOW FAR DO YOU THINK THIS
WILL GO TO HOLDING TRUMP, A
FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AND A CURRENT
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
ACCOUNTABLE?
>> WELL I THINK THAT IS REALLY A
POLITICAL QUESTION.
NOT A LEGAL ONE.
BECAUSE THE QUESTION IS WHETHER
OR NOT VOTERS CARE THAT HE FIRST
OF ALL PAYS VERY MUCH LESS TAXES
THAN MANY AMERICANS,
PARTICULARLY 2020 PAID NO INCOME
TAX AT ALL DESPITE HIS EXTENSIVE
INCOME AND BUSINESS DEALINGS.
BUT WHAT IT DETERMINED IS
WHETHER OR NOT PEOPLE WILL CARE
ABOUT THIS SORT OF ISSUE IN AWAY
THAT THEY DIDN'T IN THE PRIOR
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
GOING FORWARD, I THINK THAT